the chase
lasted just a few seconds
then adam toledo was shot dead by a
police officer
and now this image of the 13 year old
boy has gone viral
how did this happen
the sound of gunshots drew chicago
police to the area around 2 30 a.m
on the 29th of march officer stillman
gets out of his car
20 seconds later adam lay dying on the
floor
footage from body worn cameras and cctv
was released
it had previously been suggested the
teen was armed
when the fatal shot was fired sky news
has gone through the footage to assess
in detail what the videos can tell us
about the moment the trigger was pulled
the confrontation and shooting happened
in just
three seconds we've broken the footage
down
frame by frame after a short chase
at 2 38 38 in the morning officer
stillman yelled to adam to show if he is
unarmed
[Music]
a second later adam's right arm moves
something appears to be in his hand
another second later at 2 38 and 40
seconds
adam raises both his hands empty
into the air then he is shot
by 2 38 41 the 13 year old is on the
floor
dying chicago police
now say adam was holding a gun before he
was shot
with body worn cameras capturing footage
of the gun on the floor near adam
we can compare that footage with the
glimpse we get of adam's right hand
the images are too blurry to compare the
shapes exactly
the light tip of the gun appears to
match what could be in adam's hand
we can also see his right hand or
something in it
is dark compared to his left hand but
this could be a trick of the light
looking at other frames and footage
here adam's hand looks dark and one
frame later
it looks light a cctv camera shows us
what happens behind the fence
at the time police say adam was holding
the gun
letting the footage play adam's arm
appears to move behind the fence
and it is not possible to isolate a
moment showing adam's arm
fully extending behind the fence from
both the body camera footage
and this feed adam runs to the end of
this gap in the fence
pauses and then turns with his hands up
this is the location of the gun found on
the floor
compared to where adam paused by the
fence
a second later in the moment before the
gun is fired
adam raised his hands they are visibly
empty
shots fired satisfied getting an
ambulance up here now four seconds after
adam was shot
officer stillman radios his colleagues
to report he had fired his gun
and to request an ambulance
and goes on to give him cpr
adam's shooting is being investigated
while
officer stillman has been temporarily
given administrative duties
the 13 year old latino's death has
sparked anger in the u.s
and has coincided with the trial of the
policeman
who has been found to have murdered
george floyd whose death last year
saw the resurgence of the black lives
matter movement